Just to put our discussion in perspective, let's look
at a traditional structure of an operating system. In
the traditional structure of the operating system there is
something called a page cache, which is in DRAM, and
this page cache is supporting both the file system
and the virtual memory subsystem. And the file system has
opened files explicitly from the storage and they live
in the page cache that is in the physical memory.
And similarly, processes are executing in the virtual memory
and the virtual memory of every process has to
be backed by physical memory. Therefore, the page cache
in DRAM contains the contents of the virtual pages.
And of course, all these virtual pages are in
the storage subsystem. So let's, for the purpose of
our discussion, we will focus only on the virtual
memory subsystem. And in the virtual memory subsystem the
data structures, that are kept per process
in a traditional structure, is there is a
PCB, there is a process context block, or
process control block, that contains information specific to
that particular process in terms of, you know,
in terms of memory management, the memory footprint
of that process. And a page table that
describes the mapping between the virtual pages that
is occupied by the process and the physical
memory that has been allocated in the DRAM by
the operating system for backing the virtual pages
of that process. And if the operating system is
also managing the TLB and software then there
will be a global data structure that describes the
current occupancy of the TLB for that particular
process. So, these are the things that it has
per process and of course all the virtual pages
for the process are resident on the storage subsystem
so that if there is a page fault, the
missing virtual page can be brought from the storage subsystem
into the page cache for future access by the
process. So, this is your traditional structure. And what we
want to do is, for scalability, we want to
eliminate as much of the centralized data structures as possible.
That's the key thing that we're going to look at. How we
can do that so that the operating system service will be scalable.